you worked on Speed Racer which I
absolutely love and this every time I
talk to you I try to bring up something
I want to bring up Speed Racer today one
of the things that I love about that
movie is that they the wachowski's made
a live-action cartoon everything's in
focus in the frame and a lot of people
don't realize it but can you sort of
talk about what it was like working on
that project and the fact that there
were some great people that have now
gone on to have their own careers who
also worked on Speed Racer are you
kidding yeah a ton
um look when they first when they first
we had just got done with all the
matrixes and we had done Vendetta at
that point
um no Chelsea's game hey we want to do
the live action version of Speed Racer
and anybody from the same generation
that we're from is like oh my God Racer
X that's the coolest character ever so
we you know obviously being some people
I was still partnering up with Dave
Leach at the time we still were running
our sun company 8711 so we're just like
oh my God speed racer what are we going
gonna do where are we going to shoot
this how cars we're going to need but
and we had talked to the luchowskis and
I was like well we're thinking about you
know doing this in a very anime look
um almost with different layer like
these big composition shots but we might
need some real driving like we're
scouting the Italian Alps Swiss Alps
Monaco all these great plays that you do
driving and you know by the time we get
done with all the VFX uh theoretics on
it and stuff like okay well we'll use
motion based systems because we wanted
to move the background and stuff as well
um so it became a much different kind of
movie more technological movie than a
practical
which is super interesting to us at the
time because we've done so much
practical so we ended up shooting in
Berlin on the sound stages there
at babblesburg and
when they you know they started having
these big concept meetings about how we
were going to do it in terms of there's
always at least four layers right your
foreground just because you want to keep
Infinity focused and you want to do all
the wipes and stuff you go to the
slide-ins so there's the first unit that
does all the main right in your face
stuff there's the second unit the
background or second tier cast layer or
like as the cast is walking it back
depending on who that would be in the
blocking third tier would be you know
the dog the chimpanzee the animals all
the action stuff and then they'd put in
the fourth layer which is the VFX blue
screen environmental stuff so four
layers four different versions of comps
depending on where the cast would go who
was in what layer four different
directors to handle it all and you know
an amazing VFX Department from John
Gator and Dan glass that would put it
all together and you know you first hear
that and you're like I'm sorry play that
back what what
who he talking about he's like well I'm
going to shoot each scene three or four
times in different layers and we're
gonna stick them together
we're like yeah okay
but then we get there and we start doing
the process I think I learned more
you know having come from second unit
you deal with a lot with VFX you know
it's not just stunts you have to learn
how to composite put things together how
to use blue screens effectively and
really what what
um you know how to run a plate unit just
really how to stitch movies together
from the VFX and practical side
and what I had learned up to that point
was pretty significant we were fortunate
to work on some very big budget and very
large Productions that used enhanced VFX
in the combination of practical but
Speed Racer kind of put them all to
shame because now you had to think very
much three-dimensionally and how we were
wrapping around and anticipate you had
to do your homework every morning with
the other units were shooting we'd meet
with the wachowskies they'd give the
goals they'd have to block it and then
we'd be reactionary to what they wanted
then we have to go back two or three
times to get it right it was just yeah I
I think some people would have thought
it arduous and tedious but we were just
oh my God every day is a challenge to
try and it's like a puzzle every day you
walked into the room with you and you're
like okay what do we have to do
so after a couple months of that I don't
know it was one of the most challenging
things we got to do and it was one of
the most I guess experiential things we
were learning every day and you know
sometimes movie making can be a little
tedious you know wide shot media
hopefully you don't think that but some
do this was every day was like okay I'm
gonna have to relearn how to do this and
you walk away after that and then you
see it all come together which is an
entirely new experience when you see
editorial on VFX put it together again I
think you could interview Dave the same
way and it was just a massive massive
learning curve which helps benefit today
because now you can actually
you know one of the things one of my
mentors said to me if you want to be a
good director you have to speak several
languages and they don't mean cultural
languages they meant you have to speak
art design you have to speak production
design you have to speak cinematography
you have to speak you know acting you
have to speak lighting you have to speak
props you have to speak it can't just go
give me my vision that doesn't do you do
it to other people in your head you see
a tree but when you say I want a tree
there's a million types of trees
everyone's got a different one in their
head you know if a stun guy comes to you
and goes hey what do you think of this
shot they're not asking what you think
of the comp they're asking you you know
what do I need do I need to stunt double
is it going to be wire work how are we
going to cut this so like you know when
a wardrobe person goes you know blue
they're like okay is that going to kick
like you have to speak their language
and that's how you become a more
efficient leader
what we learned on Speed Racer is to
speak a very high highbrow kind of VFX
compositing and filmmaking which today
literally on every Wick I do or every
other project I produce on allows me to
be a little bit better of a director and
a filmmaker so thank you to Speed Racer
I don't think I've ever learned as much
in such a short period of time uh thank
you for sharing that story I love that
movie and um you know it's just it's
just such a great film
um which of the things that you worked
on as a stunt coordinator do you think
doesn't get enough credit in terms of
the stunts that you pulled off and maybe
people just didn't realize like how hard
they were to do or just a film that you
want to sort of you know shine a light
on wow
um I'll go two directions with you
Speed Racer has some interesting stuff
on it but again nothing that you really
couldn't sort out but it was a huge
learning thing in its combination I I go
back to like you'll laugh but I go back
to like the first Expendables all I got
to do with Stallone and state them and
the guys look we that was Jason Statham
in the front of that that c47 you know
over mangro Chiba like we were not
goofing around that was real napolin
that was real diesel fuel those were
real fire burns like every gag in that
movie no matter how whack you think it
is is a practical gag their slight CG
enhancement on some of the the M60
rounds and all that stuff but like
that's those are real big motor blasts
that's probably the last big old school
stuff they've ever done like you have to
go back and really I mean they did
digital enhancement to cut the guys in
half with the big gun what I would say
between Rambo the new Ram not first
blood but Rambo and the first
Expendables I think between those two
Stallone insisted on practical gags I
mean that in and of itself the the
amount we did in the time we did it in
practical gags with squibs and fire was
it makes my hands Shake today it makes
my palms sweaty because every day
something epic could go wrong and you
had to have your [ __ ] together you
couldn't just say well fix it in post
We'll erase the wire like we're out in
the middle of Thailand and you had to
get it right and that was you know you
know 11 stunt teams from all over the
world doing that was impressive the
other thing on the other spectrum of the
scale this is a little known movie that
I probably wasn't received all that well
I I went in and did a bunch of work on
After Earth for M night shyaman there
was one little sequence where Jaden
Smith has to jump off the cliff and the
final picture they did a ton of digital
work and it looks like it was against
blue screen but for two weeks me and one
of the best aerial coordinators in the
business a guy named Tim Rigby far the
best wingsuit guys on the planet went to
the Swiss Alps and off the Iger we did
14 000 foot wingsuit jumps they call it
proximity flying where every jump you
know really bad things can happen for
the cameraman who has to fly with a a 45
pound camera on his head so you can
imagine what that is as he's literally
just a few meters Off the Wall going at
terminal velocity following another guy
weaving the thing to this day it is the
most I even get choked up thinking about
it it's the most hair raising most
you're on the ground just going please
don't die please don't like you've heard
the best in the world but once they
leave that helicopter at 14 000 feet
they come into about 12 000 feet where
they have to link up against the Iger
and go down and follow each other
through some of the most insane weather
conditions that the Swiss Alps can offer
when you finally see those two
parachutes open
there is no describing the amount of
relief for like
it's like it still gets me going today
and we did that over the course of two
weeks I remember the day when you know
you're checking off your shot list and
we finally get footage and then you're
just well it's still nice weather we can
go back and you just know no we're done
we're done and that was the biggest
relief I've ever felt in my career that
we got amazing footage whether it made
the final product or not and uh push I
think we pushed the limits of what at
least in that endeavor human beings
could do we walked away without a
scratch and that is one of my proudest
moments so I'd go with those two both
great stories and uh yeah I could never
I could never do these things just never
never I don't know if I do them again
I'm glad I did them but I'm good we
rolled the dice and we pushed and the
universe didn't push back so we're good